the conflict between israelis and
palestinians is intensifying
hamas militants have been launching
hundreds of rockets into israel
and israeli forces have been responding
with devastating airstrikes on gaza
the escalating tensions are also
spilling over into street violence in
several israeli cities
home to both arabs and jews
this arab man was pulled from his car
and beaten by right-wing israeli
nationalists
it's the first act of nationalist
violence to receive
direct condemnation from the prime
minister
nothing justifies the lynching of arabs
by jews
or the lynching of jews by arabs it's
unacceptable we will not
tolerate this this violence is not us
the conflict can be seen etched across
the skyline
hamas unleashed a stream of rocket fire
towards israel
in retaliation for the destruction of a
building in gaza by israel
these are the most intense hostilities
that the country has seen in seven
years
it is particularly bad in mixed jewish
arab towns
with relentless rocket fire and rioting
the palestinians message to israel and
the jewish settlers
is loud and clear
i address my words specifically to
america and to israel
enough is enough leave us
we will remain thorns in your eyes we
will not
leave our homeland we will not leave our
country
the u.s maintained its support for
israel in its call for peace on
wednesday
my expectation and hope is that
this will be closing down
sooner than later but israel has a right
to defend itself when you have thousands
of rockets flying into
your territory
israeli's defense was to target the
hamas militants
they say many senior commanders have
been killed
but the attacks have also claimed the
lives of palestinian civilians
neither side is showing any sign of
backing down
prompting the united nations to warn a
full-scale
civil war
speak now to lynn hastings she's deputy
special coordinator for the middle east
peace process
and united nations resident coordinator
for the occupied palestinian territory
she joins us
from jerusalem thanks for being with us
ms hastings
first of all give us your assessment of
the situation there right now
thanks terry uh generally speaking i
think most of the videos
have spoken for that very question
but the situation is very alarming and i
use that word purposefully because
it is something that the world needs to
be paying attention to finally
that the situation here is going in the
wrong direction
this latest escalation shows the depth
of the problems between the palestinians
and the israelis
your office at the u.n has warned that
this conflict could turn into
all-out war what would that look like
well that's a good question um obviously
the situation right now
some some could call it to be all out
war
what we are concerned about in addition
to the situation in gaza
is the spillover as your reporter has
described
into israel we're seeing clashes all
over israel and we are concerned about
the regional impact as well
you what are you and your other
colleagues at the un
doing to stop this fighting because many
people do look to the u.n
to broker a piece
sure of course um just first and
foremost
in terms of what the un is doing we are
of course continuing to provide
humanitarian assistance on the ground
and while some people don't see this as
connected to
the political situation it is very much
needed to ensure that people's needs are
met in these times so for example
fuel is no longer going into gaza which
means hospitals water and sanitation
plants and
access to water itself will be severely
limited when the fuel runs out on sunday
so that's one thing that we're doing
we're responding to try and save lives
as this conflict goes on
the second thing of course is that the
united nations has a mandate to try and
broker peace
the special coordinator himself it has
been working
relentlessly with the various
interlocutors
here on the ground the parties others
regionally and of course
other member states of the security
council and the quartet for the middle
east peace process
this may not sound like a lot to a lot
of your viewers
but this is what will bring the
escalation
down and we need to focus on these types
of efforts the humanitarian assistance
and working with all the parties
involved to ensure that there's a
de-escalation in place your office
at the un is responsible for
coordinating what you continue to call
the middle east peace process
where does that process stand now
um currently it is not
proceeding which i think is very obvious
by what your viewers have seen and what
we're describing here
with rocker rockets flying everywhere
and that's again
why we need this escalation to stop
so we can get people back to the table
um we're briefing the security council
member states
who obviously have a lot of influence on
where this is going
so as it stands now that's what we're
doing we're working with all those who
can influence the situation and bring
this violence to a stop
what message do you have to the parties
in this conflagration
well again obviously stop the fighting
it's civilians who are suffering
um as i said no access to
water sanitation
electricity health care is already
suffering because
of the uh coveted pandemic so that's the
first thing there obviously needs to be
a de-escalation the second thing
is we need humanitarian access into and
out of gaza
our staff needs to be able to get in and
out and we need to be able to bring
goods in um and of course stop the
unilateral actions that are taking place
many of those have already been
described by a number of the member
states before the security council and
in other media
um briefings those include things like
evictions
in east jerusalem increasing settlement
expansion
subtler violence demolitions of
palestinian property in both east
jerusalem
and in the west bank and the inability
of
palestinians to be able to build on
their own land in east jerusalem
and in parts of the west bank as well
those
actions do not serve a peace process at
all
and they need to stop as do of course
rockets from gaza and other violence
throughout the palestinian territory and
now as i said before we're seeing in
israel
okay miss hastings thank you very much
for your time today that was lynn
hastings deputy special coordinator for
the middle east peace process
at the u.n thank you terry